Le cancer est aujourd'hui
la première cause de mortalité en France.
Il tue environ 150 000 personnes par an
et ce sont près de 300 000 nouveaux cas
que l'on diagnostique chaque année.
Quand on nous parle du cancer,
c'est souvent pour évoquer ses causes,
comme par exemple le tabac ou l'exposition aux rayons UV.
Mais on nous explique rarement
ce qu'est réellement cette maladie
et par quels mécanismes elle peut apparaître.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler de ces mécanismes
mais aussi de l'évolution et du traitement des cancers
et pour cela je me suis rendu à l'institut Gustave Roussy
♪ [Générique] ♪
Tout d'abord le cancer n'est pas vraiment une maladie,
mais une famille de maladies
qui se caractérisent par une prolifération
anormale de cellules dans un tissu.
Alors voyons ensemble ce que ça veut dire.
Comme tous les êtres vivants,
nos organismes sont faits de cellules,
environ 100 000 milliards pour un être humain adulte.
Les cellules identiques sont regroupées en tissus
qui à leur tour peuvent constituer des organes.
À tout moment de notre vie, des cellules meurent, c'est normal.
Et d'autres sont créées pour les remplacer :
environ 200 milliards chaque jour.
Ces nouvelles cellules apparaissent
par division de cellules existantes,
c'est le mécanisme de la mitose.
Chez un être humain adulte et en bonne santé,
il existe un équilibre entre le nombre de cellules
qui meurent et celles qui sont créées par mitose.
Un cancer, c'est quand un groupe
de cellules dans un de nos tissus
brise cet équilibre et se met à se diviser de façon incontrôlée.
On se retrouve alors avec un amas de cellules
dégénérées que l'on appelle une tumeur.
Et vous savez peut-être que toutes les tumeurs
ne sont pas problématiques, certaines sont bénignes,
mais quand une tumeur devient envahissante,
c'est là que l'on parle de cancer.
On entend tous presque chaque semaine
parler des causes du cancer,
mais comment on passe par exemple du tabac,
au fait que des cellules se divisent de façon incontrôlée?
Et bien pour le comprendre on va plonger au cœur des cellules,
et s'intéresser au mécanisme d'apparition d'une tumeur cancéreuse.
Vous l'avez compris, une tumeur c'est quelque chose
d'anormal ; ce n'est pas censé se produire.
La division cellulaire est un processus très encadré, très régulé
et il existe des dizaines de mécanismes
qui sont là pour la contrôler, la surveiller
et maintenir cet équilibre entre le nombre de cellules qui meurent
et celles qui sont produites par division cellulaire.
Voyons quelques uns de ces mécanismes qui sont là
pour assurer que la prolifération des cellules
se fasse de manière contrôlée.
Tout d'abord, une cellule n'est censée se diviser
que quand on lui demande de le faire,
quand elle reçoit un signal pour ça.
Et ensuite, à l'inverse, elle doit arrêter de se diviser
quand elle reçoit un signal contraire
et de toute façon, même si on ne lui dit pas,
une cellule n'est pas censée continuer à se diviser
si elle sent qu'elle n'a plus de place autour d'elle.
Et puis même si une cellule se met à défaillir,
il existe des mécanismes de réparation,
de son ADN notamment,
qui sont là pour, en quelque sorte, la ramener à la raison.
Si malgré tout ces réparations échouent,
il existe encore un autre mécanisme
qui doit pousser les cellules défaillantes à se suicider.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'apoptose.
Ça n'a rien d'exceptionnel comme situation,
le suicide programmé des cellules qui ne fonctionnent plus
correctement est quelque chose de tout à fait courant,
cela concerne environ 60 milliards
de nos cellules chaque jour.
Et si vraiment aucun de ces mécanismes ne répond,
il existe encore une protection supplémentaire.
C'est le fait qu'une cellule possède, en principe,
une limite sur le nombre de divisions successives
qu'elle peut subir, entre 50 et 60,
c'est ce qu'on appelle la limite de Hayflik.
Cette limite est due au fait que chaque fois qu'une cellule
se divise, elle doit faire une copie de son ADN,
pour que ses deux cellules filles aient chacune
le bon nombre de chromosomes
et cette opération raccourcit légèrement
l'extrémité des chromosomes.
Ce qu'on appelle les télomères.
Quand les télomères sont trop raccourcis,
la cellule ne peut plus fonctionner et meurt.
Bref, vous voyez que normalement, une cellule
ne doit pas se mettre à se diviser de façon incontrôlée.
Il existe tout un tas de couches successives
de protections pour empêcher que ça n'arrive.
Mais évidemment, il y a tellement de divisions
chaque jour dans un organisme
que régulièrement, dans des cellules, un ou plusieurs
de ces mécanismes se mettent à ne pas fonctionner.
Si un seul de ces mécanismes déraille,
ce n'est pas forcément très grave
parce que les autres sont là pour le rattraper.
Mais si par malheur, un jour, dans une cellule,
il y a trop de ces mécanismes de protection qui sont inactifs,
cette cellule peut échapper à la régulation,
se mettre à se diviser de façon incontrôlée et créer une tumeur.
Mais qu'est-ce qui fait que certains de ces mécanismes
peuvent se mettre à ne plus fonctionner?
Eh bien, c'est un affaire de gène,
Derrière chacun de ces mécanismes de contrôle,
il y a des gènes
et si un mécanisme se met à dérailler,
c'est que l'un des gènes qui le pilote est altéré.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Ce qu'on constate, c'est que pour qu'une cellule
se mette à proliférer anormalement,
et à peut-être causer un cancer,
il faut qu'un certain nombre des gènes qu'elle porte
et qui contrôlent cette division se trouvent abîmés.
On peut donc dire que, en un certain sens,
le cancer est une maladie génétique.
Alors attention, généralement quand on parle de maladie
génétique, on pense aux maladies héréditaires.
Une maladie héréditaire, c'est quand
vous possédez un gène défectueux
qui vous a été passé par l'un de vos parents ou les deux
et qui se trouve là depuis votre première cellule,
dès la fécondation.
Puisque quand une cellule se divise l'ADN est répliqué,
le gène défectueux sera présent
dans toutes les cellules de votre corps.
La différence entre le cancer et une maladie héréditaire,
c'est que dans le cancer, les gènes défectueux
ne sont présents que dans certaines cellules.
Je vous ai dit que lors d'une division, l'ADN est répliqué,
mais cette copie n'est pas toujours parfaite.
Il peut y avoir des minuscules changements
au niveau d'une cellule,
des erreurs de copie, des mutations
et ces mutations sont aléatoires,
donc différentes d'une cellule à l'autre.
Je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure, il existe un mécanisme
de réparation de l'ADN qui permet de corriger les mutations,
mais on sait que ce mécanisme n'est pas efficace à 100%
et l'ADN d'une cellule subit en moyenne 10.000 lésions par jour.
Et donc, à un moment donné, dans une de nos cellules,
il peut y avoir une mutation qui invalide un des mécanismes
de contrôle de la prolifération cellulaire.
Alors on l'a dit tout à l'heure, s'il y a un mécanisme
qui déraille, ce n'est pas forcément très grave
parce que des mécanismes de contrôle, il y en a plusieurs.
Sauf que, si une cellule se retrouve avec une mutation,
cette mutation va être recopiée lors de sa division
et elle va passer à toutes ses cellules filles.
Et un jour, sous l'effet du hasard, une de ses descendantes
va subir une deuxième mutation
qui va faire tomber un deuxième mécanisme de contrôle.
Et ainsi de suite, les mutations s'accumulent
et un jour, la faute à pas de chance,
une des cellules se retrouve avec suffisamment de mutations
pour échapper à tous les mécanismes de contrôle
et elle se met alors à se diviser de façon incontrôlée.
Et bien sûr le drame, c'est que toutes les cellules
qu'elle produit en se divisant sont identiques à elle,
donc elles aussi se mettent
à se diviser de façon incontrôlée
et c'est comme ça qu'on se retrouve avec une tumeur.
Vous comprenez que pour qu'une cellule
se mette à devenir potentiellement cancéreuse,
il faut que plusieurs mutations s'accumulent au cours du temps.
Comme c'est un processus aléatoire,
chaque cancer aura un profil génétique différent
qui va dépendre bien sûr du tissu
ou de l'organe dans lequel il se produit
mais aussi de la séquence des mutations qui l'ont engendré.
Mais on retrouve des régularités, des séquences
de mutations qui semblent en favoriser d'autres.
Par exemple, il existe un gène appelé P53,
dont on constate qu'il a subi une mutation
dans plus de la moitié des cancers.
Ce gène semble impliqué dans plusieurs
des mécanismes de contrôle dont on a parlé
et on le surnomme parfois le gardien du génome.
♪ [Générique] ♪
...
On l'a vu, ce qui engendre un cancer,
c'est une succession, une accumulation de mutations,
c'est pour cela qu'un cancer a rarement
une cause ou une origine unique.
C'est un ensemble de causes : héréditaires,
environnementales, liées à notre comportement
qui vont favoriser l'apparition de mutations.
Ces mutations s'accumulent les unes après les autres,
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour, une de nos cellules se retrouve
avec une combinaison perdante de mutations.
Alors quand je dis que c'est rarement une seule cause,
il y a évidemment des exceptions.
Il y a des circonstances, par exemple l'exposition
à de très fortes doses de radioactivité,
qui peuvent provoquer tellement de mutations
qu'elles vont engendrer un cancer à elles seules.
Il y a aussi quelques facteurs héréditaires
qui vont favoriser l'apparition de certaines mutations.
La plupart du temps ça n'implique pas
qu'on développe un cancer à coup sûr,
mais il existe par exemple un gène, appelé BRCA1
dont on sait qu'il multiplie par 6 ou 7 le risque
d'avoir un cancer du sein chez la femme.
Vous en avez peut-être déjà entendu parler
dans le cas d'Angelina Jolie.
Mais même quand il y a des prédispositions génétiques,
l'apparition d'un cancer reste un phénomène aléatoire
qui dépend d'une combinaison de facteurs
liés à notre environnement et à nos comportements.
Pour se prémunir du cancer, ça parait clair :
tout ce qui favorise les mutations, c'est-à-dire
tout ce qui agresse notre ADN, est mauvais.
Le tabac, certains produits chimiques, l'alcool...
Et oui, il ne faut pas l'oublier, l'alcool est un cancérigène avéré,
mais aussi l'obésité, l'amiante,
l'exposition au soleil (notamment aux UV),
la radioactivité, les rayons X, certains agents infectieux
comme par exemple le papillomavirus,
un mauvais régime alimentaire avec
trop de charcuterie par exemple, etc...
Mais attention, ce n'est pas l'abus de saucisson
qui va causer un cancer à lui tout seul,
par contre, il peut participer un peu
à l'accumulation de mutations
dans des tissus qui seraient au contact avec des taux
trop élevés de sel, comme par exemple dans l'estomac.
Pour se tenir au courant de ce qui peut
favoriser l'apparition d'un cancer,
il existe un organisme appelé l'IARC :
l'Agence Internationale pour la Recherche sur le Cancer,
qui classe les différentes substances et comportements.
Il existe 5 classes pour l'IARC.
La classe 1, c'est "cancérigène avéré pour l'homme",
comme le tabac ou l'alcool.
Au fait, on entend parfois cancérigène ou cancérogène :
on considère que c'est synonyme.
Dans la classe 1, outre le tabac et l'alcool,
on trouve aussi le plutonium,
la noix de bétel, le fait d'être ramoneur, les rayons
du soleil ou l'utilisation d'une lampe à bronzer.
La classe 2A, c'est "cancérigène probable",
c'est-à-dire qu'on a des preuves limitées
de son caractère cancérigène pour l'être humain,
mais qu'on a pu le montrer de manière avérée,
par exemple chez l'animal.
Dans la classe 2A, on a le glyphosate,
le fameux composé actif du Roundup,
certains composés à base de plomb, la malaria,
mais aussi les boissons servies
à une température supérieure à 65°C,
le travail de nuit, ou le fait d'être coiffeur ou barbier.
Dans la classe 2B, on a les "cancérigènes possibles"
pour lesquels on a des soupçons, mais peu de preuves.
Le nickel, les champs électromagnétiques, le dioxyde de titane,
l'aloe vera ou bien le fait d'être pompier.
La classe 3, c'est celle des produits dits "inclassables"
pour lesquels on n'a pas de preuves suffisantes,
ni dans un sens, ni dans l'autre.
On y trouve la caféine, le paracétamol,
les champs électriques
et aussi le dinitroso-penthaméthylène-tétramine.
Vous ne savez pas ce que c'est ? Bah moi non plus...
Et enfin, la classe 4, c'est celle des produits classés
"probablement non cancérigènes",
c'est-à-dire qu'on dispose de preuves solides du fait
qu'elle n'augmente pas le risque de cancer
et bizarrement, dans cette classe, on ne trouve
qu'une seule substance : le caprolactame.
Alors soyons clairs, ce classement
cause beaucoup de confusions.
Par exemple, il y a peu de temps,
la viande rouge transformée,
comme par exemple le saucisson ou le bacon,
a été mise en classe 1 : "cancérigène avéré".
Est-ce que ça veut dire qu'en mangeant trop de bacon
je vais finir par développer un cancer ?
Alors non... Il y a une chose essentielle à comprendre
sur le classement de l'IARC,
c'est qu'il est basé sur le degré de certitude,
pas sur le niveau de risque.
Vous sentez bien qu'entre le bacon et le plutonium
qui sont tous les 2 en classe 1,
il y a une différence de risque.
Mais pour les 2, on a la certitude scientifique
qu'ils jouent un rôle, donc ils sont en classe 1.
Prenons un exemple fictif pour mieux comprendre :
si demain on prouve avec une certitude scientifique
que la consommation quotidienne de plus d'1kg
de truffes augmente le risque de cancer de 0,001%,
et bien la truffe ira en classe 1.
Même si le risque est très faible,
même si l'exposition aux truffes est négligeable,
si on a la certitude que l'effet existe,
aussi faible soit-il, ce sera la classe 1.
Ce qui compte pour le classement de l'IARC
c'est le niveau de certitude, pas l'ampleur du risque.
Personnellement, je trouve ça assez maladroit
comme façon de communiquer
parce que du coup on retrouve dans la classe 1,
pêle-mêle, des choses très risquées et peu risquées,
des choses très répandues et peu répandues.
Et ça brouille le message pour le grand public,
d'autant que bien souvent dans les médias,
les différences sont occultées
et on parle simplement de "classé cancérigène",
sans préciser de quelle classe on parle :
"avéré", "probable", ou juste "possible".
Gardez ça en tête la prochaine fois
que vous lirez un gros titre
sur le fait que tel ou tel truc a été classé cancérigène.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Maintenant qu'on a passé en revue
les mécanismes d'apparition du cancer
et les causes qui peuvent en être à l'origine,
je voudrais revenir sur ce qui se passe ensuite :
l'évolution des cancers.
On l'a vu, aussi incroyable que ça puisse paraître,
au départ d'un cancer, il y a une seule cellule,
une, qui a accumulé suffisamment de mutations
pour échapper au contrôle de la prolifération cellulaire,
se mettre à se diviser de façon incontrôlée
et engendrer une tumeur.
Je l'évoquais au début, et c'est très important,
une tumeur ne fait pas forcément un cancer,
il existe des tumeurs bénignes.
L'exemple le plus connu ce sont les grains de beauté,
mais il y a aussi les verrues,
ou certaines tumeurs qui peuvent être de taille
importante, mais sans gravité pour l'organisme.
Ce qui fait qu'une tumeur peut devenir maligne,
c'est-à-dire cancéreuse,
c'est notamment sa capacité à continuer à bénéficier
des ressources de l'organisme en les détournant.
Pour cela, il faut que la tumeur soit notamment capable
de faire apparaître des vaisseaux sanguins
qui vont continuer à l'alimenter en oxygène
et lui permettre de proliférer.
On appelle ça l'angiogenèse.
L'autre mécanisme qui peut caractériser
l'évolution des cancers, ce sont les métastases.
Une métastase, c'est quand une cellule cancéreuse
arrive à s'échapper de son tissu d'origine
pour trouver refuge dans un autre organe
et y causer une nouvelle tumeur.
Cette migration se fait généralement par le sang ou la lymphe
et il existe des tissus qui vont plus naturellement
être susceptibles de recevoir des métastases.
Mais il faut retenir que, d'une part,
tous les cancers n'en font pas
et d’autre part, même en cas de métastases,
un cancer reste de son type initial.
Un cancer du poumon qui fait des métastases dans le foie
reste un cancer du poumon, pas un cancer du foie.
Je l'ai dit en introduction, le cancer est aujourd'hui
la première cause de mortalité en France.
Cette mortalité diminue,
mais elle a diminué moins vite
que celle des maladies cardiovasculaires
qui était autrefois la première cause de mortalité.
Malgré tout, la probabilité de survivre à un cancer
est très différente d'un type de cancer à l'autre.
Le tableau que vous voyez ici vous montre trois choses,
le nombre de nouveaux cas, chaque année,
de différents types de cancers,
la mortalité associée et le taux de survie
qui représente la proportion des patients
qui sont encore vivants 5 ans après un diagnostic.
Vous voyez par exemple que le cancer
le plus fréquent est celui de la prostate,
mais qu'il tue beaucoup moins,
en proportion, que d'autres cancers.
Il est temps maintenant de parler
des traitements possibles du cancer
et des développements de recherche associés.
Tout d'abord, on l'a dit, le cancer
est plutôt une famille de maladies,
donc il ne faut pas s'attendre à ce qu'un jour
on trouve un médicament unique, universel.
Chaque cancer est différent, d'une part
parce que les tissus impliqués varient,
mais aussi parce que la succession
de mutations qui a engendré la tumeur
est potentiellement très différente d'un cas à un autre.
Chaque cancer a un profil génétique particulier
qui nécessite un traitement personnalisé et adapté.
Le premier type de traitement
qu'on peut envisager, c'est la chirurgie.
Il s'agit simplement, si on peut dire,
de faire une ablation de la tumeur.
Le gros problème c'est d'être sûr d'absolument tout enlever,
on l'a dit, une seule cellule qui défaille
peut engendrer une tumeur
donc si l'opération chirurgicale ne laisse
ne serait-ce qu'une seule cellule cancéreuse,
cela peut compromettre la guérison.
Pour s'assurer de ça, le chirurgien qui enlève une tumeur
doit généralement couper largement
dans la partie saine du tissu,
ce qui n'est pas toujours possible ou souhaitable.
Autre type de traitement qu'on peut utiliser : la radiothérapie.
Elle consiste à envoyer des rayons X
sur la tumeur dans le but de la détruire.
On l'a vu, une des caractéristiques des cellules cancéreuses,
c'est qu’elles ont perdu une partie
de leur capacité à réparer leur ADN.
La radiothérapie exploite en quelque sorte cette faiblesse
puisque les rayons X ont justement pour effet
d'induire encore plus de dommages dans l'ADN
et donc de détruire la cellule.
Enfin, dernier traitement classique,
c'est la chimiothérapie.
L'idée consiste à donner au patient des médicaments
qui vont spécifiquement attaquer les cellules cancéreuses.
Mais comment fait-on pour être sûr
qu'elles vont attaquer uniquement ces cellules là
et pas les autres cellules, les cellules saines ?
On utilise des substances, comme des sels de platine,
qui vont spécifiquement endommager l'ADN
des cellules qui se divisent beaucoup.
Une fois de plus, on exploite
le fait que les cellules cancéreuses
on perdu une partie de leur capacité à réparer leur ADN,
mais également le fait que ces cellules malades
se divisent, en moyenne, beaucoup plus
fréquemment que les cellules normales.
Le problème de ces traitements par chimiothérapie,
c'est qu'ils ont tendance à avoir
des dommages collatéraux
sur des cellules qui naturellement se divisent souvent,
par exemple, les cellules du tube digestif
ou les follicules de cheveux,
d'où la perte des cheveux qui est l'effet secondaire
le plus connu des chimiothérapies.
Quand on le peut, on essaye d'utiliser
ces traitements en combinaison,
par exemple, chimiothérapie et radiothérapie,
mais il faut bien retenir qu'il n'y a pas de combinaison
miracle qui serait tout le temps supérieure aux autres.
La recherche d'un traitement efficace
dépend du profil génétique du cancer
et il varie d'une personne à l'autre,
même pour un même type de cancer.
Le choix du meilleur traitement reste une décision
de spécialiste prise en concertation.
Une petite précision au passage,
à ce stade de la vidéo, vous vous êtes rendu compte
que le cancer est une maladie
incroyablement complexe et protéiforme,
inutile de dire que les remèdes de charlatans
basés uniquement sur du jus de citron
ou de la méditation n'ont que
peu de chances d'être efficaces.
Pour terminer, je voudrais vous faire découvrir
une nouvelle famille de thérapies
qui est peut-être en train de révolutionner
la manière dont on traite certains cancers,
il s'agit de l’immunothérapie.
Et pour en savoir plus, je suis allé interroger
les chercheurs de l'institut Gustave Roussy
♪ [Générique] ♪
...
Professeur Caroline Robert, vous êtes chef du service
de Dermato-oncologie, ici à l'institut Gustave Roussy,
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
le principe de l'immunothérapie ?
L'immunothérapie, comme son nom l'indique,
c'est la thérapie, le traitement,
par l'action sur le système immunitaire.
C'est très différents des traitements comme
les chimiothérapies ou les thérapies ciblées
où on va aller essayer de détruire directement le cancer.
Ici, on va se servir de nos cellules du système
immunitaire, nos lymphocytes,
nos cellules qui normalement doivent nous protéger,
par exemple, vis-à-vis des infections
virales, bactériennes, ...
Donc ces lymphocytes, on va essayer de leur faire
comprendre qu'il faut rejeter les cellules cancéreuses.
Merci, est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser quels sont
les différents modes d'action possibles de l'immunothérapie ?
En fait, l'immunothérapie qui a marché, qui vraiment
a fait faire un pas en avant gigantesque,
c'est quand on a pensé à bloquer
des mécanismes régulateurs négatifs.
C'est un peu compliqué, mais en fait,
notre système immunitaire,
c'est un peu toujours comme ça dans l'organisme,
il y a des systèmes positifs et des systèmes négatifs,
parce qu'il faut que les réponses biologiques aient lieu
mais il ne faut pas qu'elles s'emballent trop,
donc il y a toujours des freins.
En fait, il y a des freins aussi pour
l'activation du système immunitaire
et assez récemment, on a découvert les molécules et
les récepteurs qui étaient vraiment en jeu dans ces freins,
le premier qu'on a découvert s'appelle CTLA4
et cette molécule peut être bloquée
par un anticorps qu'on injecte
et si on bloque CTLA4, on bloque son interaction avec son contre-récepteur,
on bloque un blocage donc comme on bloque
un blocage, on libère l'action du système immunitaire.
Sur quels types de cancers
ces immunothérapies sont efficaces ?
Les premiers résultats positifs, on les a eus
avec un anticorps anti CTLA4
dans le cadre des patients atteints de mélanomes
métastatiques, le mélanome c'est un cancer de la peau
qui parfois peut être grave quand il donne des métastases
et cet anticorps anti CTLA4 a été le premier traitement, en fait,
qui a démontré, sur cette population de patients
avec une maladie très grave,
qu'on pouvait vraiment prolonger de façon
significative la survie des patients.
Il y avait des patients qui survivaient
très très longtemps grâce à ce traitement.
Pour vous dire ce qui se passe dans les autres cancers,
en fait on a ouvert la voie.
Le deuxième cancer qui a été démontré
comme sensible à l'immunothérapie,
c'est le cancer du poumon, les différents
types de cancers du poumon
et là aussi, ces médicaments maintenant sont sur le marché
pour traiter différentes formes de cancers du poumon
et maintenant, il y a beaucoup d'autres cancers
qui se montrent sensibles à l'immunothérapie
avec des sensibilités variables.
Est-ce qu'il existe d'autres types de récepteurs
qu'on peut cibler avec ces immunothérapies ?
L'être vivant, c'est extrêmement complexe,
on a des tas de signaux positifs et négatifs
et bien sûr qu'il y en a d'autres
et il y en a d'autres qui sont déjà à l'essai
tout seuls et en combinaison avec les immunothérapies
qui sont déjà prouvées comme efficaces
donc on est vraiment rentrés dans l'ère
des combinaisons de traitements,
combinaisons d'immunothérapies,
séquences d'immunothérapies.
Est-ce qu'on utilise parfois ces immunothérapies
en association avec d'autres thérapies ?
Maintenant évidemment, on essaye de combiner
avec d'autres immunothérapies, donc on combine
des immunothérapies entre elles,
mais on essaye aussi d'utiliser
toutes nos autres armes anti cancer,
les chimiothérapies, les thérapies ciblées,
des molécules qui agissent directement
sur la mort cellulaire, même la radiothérapie.
Ce qu'on essaye de faire maintenant,
c'est une médecine vraiment plus intelligente,
où on regarde les choses en dynamique,
c'est-à-dire que les choses ne sont pas fixées,
nos systèmes biologiques évoluent au cours du temps,
les cancers sont sensibles,
après ils développent des résistances
et nous on le voit parce que les cancers,
parfois, répondent au traitements
et après se mettent à ne plus répondre,
ou ne répondent plus sur les différentes
métastases de la même façon.
Donc, nous on essaye avec les chercheurs,
les équipes de recherche
de faire des prises de sang et même
de prélever des fragments de tumeur,
on appelle ça une biopsie,
au fil du temps, pour comprendre
ce qui se met en place comme résistance
pour déjouer ces résistances et pour être capables
d'utiliser les armes qu'il faut au bon moment.
Professeur Caroline Robert, merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à mes questions aujourd'hui.
Vous voyez que, grâce à la recherche, on arrive
à mettre au point de nouveaux traitements
qui élargissent encore l'arsenal thérapeutique
dont on dispose pour traiter les différents cancers.
Mais il y a encore beaucoup de chemin à parcourir,
pas seulement du côté des traitements,
mais aussi de la compréhension des causes
et des mécanismes fondamentaux d'apparition des cancers.
Tenez, un simple exemple pour éveiller votre curiosité :
puisque l'apparition d'un cancer est liée à la défaillance
d'une cellule, un jour, dans notre organisme,
on devrait s'attendre à ce que
plus un organisme contient de cellules,
plus il ait de risque de développer un cancer.
Mais bizarrement, un animal comme l'éléphant
est beaucoup moins sujet au cancer que l'homme.
Comment est-ce possible ?
Le mystère a peut-être été levé
dans une étude parue en Octobre 2015.
Vous vous souvenez du gêne P53,
celui qu'on appelle le gardien du génome
et qu'on retrouve muté dans plus de la moitié des cancers
et bien les éléphants en possèdent 20 copies,
contre une seule pour les humains.
Et donc dans une cellule d'éléphant,
même si une ou plusieurs des copies du gène P53
sont mutées, et donc défaillantes,
il en reste encore plusieurs qui sont fonctionnelles.
Même si ça n'explique pas tout,
cela montre qu'il existe encore bien des choses
à comprendre au niveau fondamental
sur les moyens dont disposent les organismes
pour se prémunir naturellement des cancers.
Voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette longue vidéo.
Une vidéo un petit peu particulière,
assez différente de ce que je fais d'habitude
et qui n'aurait pas été possible
sans l'aide de plusieurs personnes
que je voudrais vraiment sincèrement remercier.
Tout d'abord, Élodie Grellier et Antoine Crouan
de l'Institut des Sciences du Cancer,
en fait ce sont eux qui m'ont ouvert
les portes de l’institut Gustave Roussy,
qui m'ont permis de rencontrer le personnel
et puis aussi surtout de faire relire mon script
par les chercheurs et les médecins de l'institut,
ce qui évidemment, sur un sujet complexe comme le
cancer, était quelque chose d'indispensable pour moi,
donc merci beaucoup à eux deux.
Et puis vous aurez remarqué aussi dans cette vidéo,
l'image était quand même un petit peu différente
de ce que je fais d'habitude
et ça c'est grâce à Raphaël Thiollier qui est réalisateur
et qui m'a proposé de venir travailler avec moi
sur ce projet donc, merci beaucoup à Raphaël.
Si ça vous intéresse, vous pouvez aller voir ce qu'il fait,
je vous mettrai le lien de son portfolio dans la description.
Voilà, d'ici là, je vous souhaite de passer un bel été,
je pense qu'il y aura quelques petites vidéos dans l'intervalle,
mais je ne sais pas encore exactement comment.
Si vous voulez des nouvelles de la chaîne,
vous pouvez en retrouver, de toute façon,
par les canaux habituels, Facebook, Twitter
et puis je vous retrouve de toute façon
dans quelques semaines pour des nouvelles vidéos.
Voilà, à bientôt.